Say that. Osda hniwi.
Osda hniwi.
Hi. I’m Patrick Del Percio
and I’m a lecturer
of Cherokee language
in the Department of
Linguistics
Now, if I want to add
some more to it
or more emphasis, I'd say
Vsgidv.
The big thing that’s hard
for people to get
is the tone and the rhythm.
Tohiquu.
Wait. [adjusts tone] Tohiquu.
The one word that comes to mind
is usdi.
and usdi.
The first word is baby.
Which is usdi.
The second word is
[different tone] usdi.
Which is small.
So you can hear that slight
change or that slight tone,
even the length of the
syllable, changes the meaning.
So if you say Tla
I’ve often heard other language
learners say that learning
the language changes
their world view.
I hope to see that
from my students.
[students enjoying class]
I hope that heritage language
learners feel more connected
to their heritage, their
ancestry, their identity.
My late mentor, Durbin Feeling,
said that he envisioned
a Cherokee renaissance.
I hope that this is a
part of that.